ladies and gentlemen welcome to the tim
dillon show they're coming for the vapes
they're coming for the nicotine they're
coming for the cigarettes i have been
clean sober dry
uh uh from the cigarette for 17 days my
last cigarette was on monday may 6th i
had a bronchial event that was not
coveted it was a sickness which has been
a blessing in disguise it has kept me uh
from the temptation of
smoking again and are you proud of me
you don't say much no no i am proud of
you yeah yeah i've told you off mike i'm
proud of you oh this is great tell me on
mike tell me publicly in front of other
people thank you stranger we've never
met clapping in the gas digital studio
again here for a few weeks
while we get things going
we have of course i'll be back in the
los angeles studio
um relatively soon we'll be back there
uh tell everybody a little bit about
this because they are trying to get rid
of cigarettes this is a big uh push now
and it's coordinated they're getting rid
of the jewel
well they're getting yeah so yesterday
because it targets the kids
isn't that what they're saying yeah
they're getting rid of the jewel because
it's marketed to kids
who are oreos marketed to you know
they're taking every means that you have
to relax
they're they're you're heading into the
worst economic climate that there's been
in 10 plus years maybe more
and they're taking every little bit of
peace
from you
uh
including your jewel
so why are they you know more about
jules than me yeah so jewel is uh it's a
nick salt and i see saul don't say that
word on the show
well that's what it is because we'll get
thrown right off
if you keep that up
well it uh so it uh they were the fda
removed juul from the stores immediately
uh why they reviewed the company's
pre-market tobacco product applications
and determined some of joule's lab
studies findings had insufficient and
conflicting data including regarding
genotoxicity and potentially harmful
chemicals leaching from the company's
proprietary e-liquid pods that have not
been adequately addressed and since 2018
they've been they've sued them uh i
believe south carolina sued them and won
a bunch of money because they've been
targeting children really this is just a
push to jewel targets uh kids with the
flavors yeah so they had cool cucumber
creme brulee
uh there was a mango there jewel is a
thing where somebody blows it
and you think you're having a stroke
because you smell like blueberries yeah
yeah yeah that's what i always thought
somebody would blow
it's like the caterpillar uh the
caterpillar from uh alice in wonderland
where they'd be like whoo oh you and
then just a plume of smoke would fill a
subway car and you'd be like am i is
this it and then you go oh somebody's
jeweling and it'll be like pumpkin pie
jewel flavor so they're getting rid of
that they're also getting rid of
nicotine in cigarettes well what's the
point
now joe biden is trying to get rid of
nicotine by the way i have called this
we have called it before
it's over
they're going to when you travel outside
of america cigarettes
in places like the uk and australia are
all
uh packaged with
uh this very alarmist packaging where
you will see uh babies born dead low
birth weight you'll see scarred lungs on
the package
on the actual bobby just pull up a uk
cigarette package to show people
or an australian cigarette package they
really want you to think twice before
buying cigarettes cigarettes also in
australia fifty dollars yeah and in the
uk they're a lot of money too but in
canada
in the uk and in australia the packaging
of the cigarettes themselves is
disturbing like when you buy it
you look at it and they show like
somebody just had a stroke
yeah
take a look at those these are this is
how they package
cigarettes
outside of america
and the cost of cigarettes outside of
america is prohibitively
high
um
i do believe we're heading for uh some
type of ban
or
another big spike in cost of cigarettes
is that unfounded is my belief unfounded
no by may 2020 20 2023 it looks like
they're going to restrict they're going
to put a cap on how much nicotine can be
in a cigarette well i i used to smoke
marlborough lights which is not a lot of
nicotine right right
yeah it's like if you're smoking
marlboro lights you're okay
but they're now they're capping that at
what they don't know yet they don't
they're they're going to bring it way
down to the to the point where it's
really not addictive
oh that's the goal
so to the point where you're no longer
addicted
to a cigarette right you don't get
hooked but then there's gonna be the
hard stuff that you can get on the
streets the black market
dark web
cigarettes
wow well
it's better to not smoke but it is very
cool to smoke especially when you're
young
and very sexy and if you are a teenager
and you're listening to this show
there's nothing better than smoking a
cigarette
truly if you can enjoy that if you don't
have asthma or something
to be 17 and smoking is beautiful that's
what life should be when you're in
college you're 19 if you're not smoking
a bot you're a [ __ ] idiot
so tim dillon tells you that when you
were young in your late teens and early
20s it's the time to be a casual smoker
and then just stop
it's not hard
pick it up
for when you should have it there's a
photo of you in france with a cigarette
when you're 21. beautiful
then cut it out
it's not a big deal
stop getting so
uh
attached to all these things
move on
um
but i don't know i don't i you know i'm
always for freedom
but i do understand that
i i am for freedom
but i also like the idea of poor people
not being able to do things they want
so i'm in that rock in a hard place
whereas i want people to be free
but the idea of cigarettes being
restricted to only luxurious
people
is also nice
you know
so
getting them out of the hands of these
bums
and putting them in the hands of rich
people
seems good i don't know
there's a lifeguard shortage and this
really concerns me and i wanted to talk
about this because so many
of my formative years in on earth were
spent as a lifeguard i was a lifeguard
at a beach club in long island whose
name i will not mention
um but it was great it was great for me
it was great for all of the people i was
uh
a smoker as a lifeguard
um i was not in the best
physical shape
but i was a pool lifeguard which did not
require a ton of physical conditioning
the ocean requires more physical
conditioning there is a lot of running
you run
uh to the surf you jump in and you pull
someone out whereas the pool lifeguard
you could kind of just fall out of your
chair
into the pool
you scoop up one of these little bums
and you say what the [ __ ] wrong with
you we'd scream at them i never saved
anyone but i imagine had i would have
yelled immediately at them like what are
you doing because their parents would
i've seen saves
and when the kid would get out of the
water the mother would grab him and
shake him and scream and go what are you
doing in front of everybody and then the
kid would be like terrified of the water
and permanently scarred but it's also
you know it is embarrassing for everyone
to see you drowned it's a public thing
right a beach club if many of you don't
know what it is it's a pool with a bunch
of cabanas around it everybody knows
everybody everybody sees what's
happening so if you're you know we had
one
half save where we kind of just dragged
the kid out and then the mother came up
to us and they're like she was like he
can swim this is humiliating now he
feels bad coming back to the pool and
it's like all right well next time we'll
just let him go blue you know we'll let
him die but it is embarrassing in
australia when we thought we were going
to drown the idea of being saved was so
mortifying to me i'd rather kind of die
especially because all i did was [ __ ] on
australia and say how lazy they all were
then for them to have to drag my fat ass
out of the water it would be humiliating
so i'd rather die i wanted to just die
but we survived and we were fine
um
but my whole thing as a lifeguard it was
it was a good experience for me and i've
talked about it many times it's a great
job for a young person it's a great job
whether you are in shape and you really
want to help people which is never what
i wanted to do but it's also a great job
for people that enjoy sitting abusing
power they like rules they like a
structure they like as jordan peterson
would say a hierarchy
they like to enforce arbitrary rules
that don't really make anyone safe
but they have power you get a whistle
and you get power and you could close
the pool and open the pool and yell at
people and ban people and give them time
out no running on the deck and at night
people would give you food and you could
eat it like people would you know i like
the 11 to 7 shift you didn't have to get
up early
and at night they would give you food
you could kind of eat it in the chair
and there were less people in the pool
and i didn't really pay that much
attention we used to get high all the
time because sometimes it would be rainy
and no one would go to the beach club
and we'd bake out the lifeguard shed get
very high like out of our minds high and
then the sun would come out and then
we'd be like [ __ ]
so then we'd be then there'd be 80
people in the pool and we're on a
lifeguard chair terrified with glasses
on so high
baked out of our mines in a chair
completely unaware of what's happening
just seeing splash
so [ __ ] up we're just seeing splashing
and like looking at each other and going
like
and just hoping to god
nothing happened because we were so
[ __ ] up i was high so many times in
that live culture one time we did
so it was supposedly miss a safe i to
this day don't remember seeing anyone
drown uh supposedly some kid's mother
jumped in to save him which is a better
system anyway strong families
but
the the owner of the beach club came out
and me and my friend jeff were sitting
there and we were like really high and
we had our glasses on thank god and he
goes i can never hear what i just heard
and i'm like what did you hear he's like
i heard that you two missed a save there
was a kid flailing around here and he
was going under and his mother had to
drag him out i'm like oh
i think he was fine
and
so that was the one time but i've never
saved anyone
thank god nobody ever drowned um
i was fired from that job i wasn't asked
back they did not like
my work ethic or whatever there were
complaints about there was like multiple
complaints about me but lifeguarding is
a good job it's a good job and you don't
have to be like this ripped adonis who's
like really hot and i mean that's a
great version of a lifeguard too but my
mother was a fat lifeguard like there's
many fat lifeguards
who come from like the um
you know more of like the public pool
space where they are just kind of
miserable angry people
that like to blow the whistle and scream
many of them were elderly we had old
lifeguards one of them was named dottie
and they would go
and blow the whistle and scream not
running
so there is that part of the job too
like there is that part of the job you
don't
have to be big it's not baywatch
you can work at a shitty
underfunded rec center
okay but that they may drown so you want
to go to like a nice suburban spot
where everybody has private swimming
lessons and they're all kind of good
that way
you know they're not drowning left and
right i mean the idea of it's just to me
they moved me to the ocean i worked on
the ocean for a few weeks because one of
the ocean guards was out and they put me
on the ocean and i mean when when i say
i had no idea what was going on i would
just stare at the ocean and i'm like i
don't know how many people were in the
world
and there was like four people in the
water if they were when i looked back if
there were two i was like i hope they
got out
i had no idea what happened i think
lifeguarding is kind of you know
whatever unless you're really focused
it's kind of like you know it's luck of
the draw
um and then the one time i got fired was
because i did i got everyone's
sandwiches for lunch
and there was a
so this is a true story somebody had had
uh they they dragged someone out of the
water and they were doing cpr on them
and they were they were fine at that
point they'd gotten up they'd coughed
the water up they were still breathing i
had gotten everyone's sandwiches i had
picked them up and then i brought them
back and i started handing out
sandwiches to people while this guy was
laying on the beach
fine just getting his breathing back
and um later they it said that i looked
um ridiculous
and it looked it was completely
unprofessional and we had a lifeguard
stand next to the town like we were a
private beach club but then there was a
town of atlantic beach which actually
had like standards and there supposedly
quote unquote uh their lifeguards were
quote horrified
that i had handed out a lunch but the
guy's not dead he's on the [ __ ]
what do you want me to do but all in all
not a bad uh
not a bad gig tell us about the shortage
oh yeah so what's going on with the
shortage well they're trying to they're
trying to get people to go all over the
local news they can make up to 24 an
hour you can make good money i don't
think that's that bad right 24 an hour
for uh i think it's great uh um so
employees from what i've watched on
these local news channels uh they don't
want to take risks due to covet what
so like mouth to mouth there's close
contact stuff like that so they're like
grossed out by the idea of having to
like put their hands on somebody and
save them because then they think they
might get cover 19. they might get
covered that's that's what they're
saying this is what they're saying this
is what they said on the news this is
the party line uh bobby i have a thing
if you want to pull it off yeah i don't
believe this at all um and then also you
know oh yeah this is it right here here
comes tits
good morning guys you know staffing
shortage this is an issue across the
board and we're seeing it at restaurants
at retail stores but here at the beach
it's a very serious situation because of
course it's a matter of life and death
now here in huntington beach this is
where the state holds annual training
sessions every year and we're seeing
what happening this morning just take a
look behind me unfortunately not enough
people coming out to recruit to train
here you can see these guys they're
getting ready for it this training
session is going to happen later today
but some of them walking out to those
blue tents they're getting ready for the
training for today you know the weather
is getting warmer people are flocking to
the beach but unfortunately not enough
people signing up to be a lifeguard um
recruitment this year according to
agencies drew in our alarmingly low
numbers typically about 300 people show
up to try out but only a hundred why do
we even just pause this for example why
do we even
why do we even have it
at like why do we even care let them
drown why is this the one
area where we pretend to care about
whether people survive
at your own risk
i mean what is this
i don't understand like why we even have
lifeguards like what this does if it's a
public
beach yeah it's a good point if it's a
public beach i think you have to swim at
your own risk
sorry
i mean i don't even know why we ha why
are we trying to prevent
the deaths of people
who are unable
to afford a membership to some type of
private beach a private beach club
public beach let them do whatever they
want there let them deliver babies on
the beach
you know no i mean obviously i'm i'm i'm
kidding but you know
the thing is
if people
you know
the job of lifeguard
you know used to be cool
when it was associated with things like
baywatch and people are like i want to
be a lifeguard so i'll get a lot of
chicks
and i think that's still what people
think of when they think of lifeguards
is
you know
here's what's happened though
over the last few years
any position of power because of covid
has become like cool people don't want
to do it anymore
like you see all these health directors
that came out and they were like no
tennis and they were all looked like
goblins and they told you you weren't
allowed to go to a park and you couldn't
skateboard and you weren't allowed on a
hiking trail and like this whole public
health apparatus that we didn't even
know existed these like [ __ ]
essentially kind of no-show jobs where
these freaks would sit around and try to
prevent i don't know
forest fires or something else we see
how well that does
whatever these people get paid to do
you know i think maybe like lifeguard
maybe kind of unfairly
or in some cases fairly maybe it doesn't
look cool anymore because it feels like
you're like a cop
maybe a lifeguard feels like you're a
beach fed
i don't know because i'm wondering why
people wouldn't want to be a lifeguard
well the other reason they decided i
don't know if this is like the boomer
just saying what he thinks on the news
but they said because you're not allowed
to be on social media or your phone
people don't want to do those jobs if
you can't just kind of scroll throughout
the day
you know like any retail job you kind of
get on your phone very interesting point
you're prevented from scrolling
of your your feed right your ig
or your tick tock
and you have to actually do something
that's maybe the actual answer that it's
actually a job that you actually have to
do
or people will die and you can i guess
get sued i don't know i never thought
about that
but
that might be potentially the actual
reason because most jobs right now are
such [ __ ] jobs that people can spend
the entirety of the job essentially
doing nothing
you know
finger [ __ ] people they like on
[ __ ] instagram or listening to this
show
you don't really have to do much but a
lifeguard you might actually
have to save somebody's life
it's a heavy job if
you approach it that way
but i would advise pool
not beach
pool guard
beach club country club
maybe get an old person every now and
then that goes down but there's not much
you can do for that you just get him out
of the pool and lay him on the deck and
call for help
um
it's a great gig for a young person
that wants to
you know make a little bit of money and
it's unfortunate and even for an older
person that wants to be a lifeguard
that's the thing if you're complaining
that you don't have any money in this
country
go be a lifeguard and and guard the
psychopaths in huntington beach
who are the most right-wing part of
california they're always protesting
they're always protesting they've got
like candace owens on a float at the
parade
it's wild down there go and guard them
if you try to save them they'll be like
get off me [ __ ] and punch you in the
face
so yeah i can understand why huntington
beach might have a shortage because
they're psychotic
they're absolutely psychotic down there
the [ __ ] wants to save them they're a
little wacky
um
i mean but i don't know i mean i don't
think it's i don't think it's the worst
idea to be a lifeguard did you have a
summer job when you were young yeah i
just worked on a ranch so i would oh
shut up
and stuff [ __ ] it wasn't like like
yellowstone you worked on a ranch
something like rope and rye but it's a
guy's ranch so i would get on a 360.
your life is so dumb
so pointless
work on a ranch
so pointless
god
so many people are bold right now and
it's disgusting but what you can do is
you can avoid baldness with keeps
keeps is awesome why because the best
way to to prevent baldness is to keep
the hair you have on your head
it helps prevent hair loss okay
keeps is great it can
stop
you from losing your hair is that
something that's good
i think so
okay
keeps is great i have a friend that's
using it
um it is amazing okay
he's using it
and you know what he says to me all the
time what's that i have my [ __ ] hair
he sounds happy so he's pleased i'd be
happy yeah wouldn't you yeah he's
keeping his hair that's right they go
for a simple affordable stress-free way
to keep your hair they have convenient
virtual doctor consultations and
medications delivered straight to your
door every three months when you don't
have to leave your home 24 7 care and
support keeps as a network of medical
advisors prescribers and care
specialists to support you in making
your hair goals a reality it's low cost
proven results
if you're ready to take action and
prevent hair loss go to k-e-e-p-s dot
com slash tim dillon to receive your
first month of treatment for free that's
k-e-e-p-s dot com tim dillon to get your
first month free k-e-e-p-s dot com slash
tim dillon
god i love athletic greens i keep
talking about this because i love it i'm
telling you right now i started taking
athletic greens because i just felt like
funk in a funk
and i mean if you want better gut health
more energy an optimized immune system
if you hate taking pills and vitamins
you want a supplement that actually
tastes great wanted to see what all the
hype was about i wanted to see what all
the hype was about did you want to see
what the hype was about yeah
so what is this stuff with one delicious
scoop of ag1 you're absorbing 75 high
quality vitamins minerals whole foods
source superfoods probiotics and
actigens to help you start your day
right this special blend of ingredients
supports your gut health your nervous
system your immune system your energy
recovery focus and aging all the things
i'm telling you you love it i love it
everyone loves it and you know why
because it works it works
how often do you have something you go
what is this but this is not that no no
it's not no
this works but is there is there a but
is there a deal oh they get a really
good is there a deal they make it easy
for you well you tell them about it
athletic greens is going to give you a
free one-year supply of immune
supporting vitamins wait a minute
hold the phone
i'm about to lose my [ __ ]
well they're gonna give you a free
one-year supply of
athletic green who's gonna give this to
you well the company i don't know that
who's shipping it i don't know who works
there how
this is very nice
you better get involved in this folks
what what's happening now they're gonna
give you a free one-year who's gonna do
it athletic greens i'm telling you i'm
trying to tell you guys damn it it's
beautiful it's vitamin d and five free
travel packs with your first purchase
that's a one year free supply all you
have to do is visit
athleticgreens.com tim dillon oh my god
again that's athleticgreens.com
to take ownership over your health and
pick up the ultimate daily
insurance athletic greens.com
but it's not that it's not that bad
now they're also saying
that temperatures are going to be so hot
that maybe it's easier to just die
it's going to be over 100 degrees
everywhere
well you have yeah like it like in the
south and stuff well it's going to be
hot
it's going to be hot in the old
antebellum south and they're they're
they're saying that might be easier for
people instead of going out to a beach
or local pool to just die in their house
it might be easier for them and we're
always trying to i think it's really
about what's easy for people and it just
may be easier to just die in the
sweltering heat it's the type of heat
where if the air conditioning goes it's
over right if like that texas energy
grid crashes
it's over
grandma's done
it's so hot
there was a guy in death valley the
other day in california he's which by
the way don't drive through that you
idiot
his car breaks down guess what happens
to him
dead
probably didn't make it long yeah yeah i
mean it's rough out there yeah so now
how hot is it going to be what are we
talking so right here we got uh
so for the next seven days highs will be
15 to 25 degrees above normal and
california will see triple digits on
thermometers from fresno and all over
the place so you're looking at uh
uh it says 65 million americans will
expect highs above 100 degrees this week
so pretty much uh half the country for
the most part it's the summer
get into it
you know
get into it like i i i don't i don't
love the whining
get into the summer you have an
opportunity right now
to [ __ ]
enjoy the weather there's so much things
that are available now that you couldn't
you couldn't do them
in a colder climate
there's a lot of things that you can do
as an american right now
that you couldn't do in a colder climate
for example
after eating at famous dave's barbecue
have a coronary or what you think is a
coronary event in your car
but ends up just being indigestion
and you were sweating it's brought on by
the heat
and you might have a nice lunch at
famous dave's get into your car
while you're adjusting yourself in your
seat you shake something loose you start
feeling a pulsating throbbing pain in
your chest
and you think to yourself [ __ ] i'm done
but it's actually indigestion and you
start pouring sweat because of the heat
these are the summer experiences that
americans are going to have
there'll be fireworks for the fourth of
july there'll be kids
running around without shoes on bikes
trying to potentially rob you
it's the summer
this is a fun
part of the you know year where people
are just hot angry
the cost of everything is up
there's going to be fights in the street
you're going to see people get real
drunk you know what's fun in the summer
those street festivals where everyone
lives in a [ __ ] and they go let's
close each side of the [ __ ] all off
and get drunk right here let's sit out
let's walk out on our [ __ ] street that
we live because we don't have any money
to go anywhere else
and let's pretend and let's have all the
kids out and they're all fighting with
pool noodles and in a few years it'll be
guns and just get them everybody boozed
up and put the [ __ ] beards in the
koozies and get [ __ ] up on your street
which sucks and you and it [ __ ] up
traffic so all the drug dealers gotta
circle back and go around and it's it's
annoying but that's what's fun you have
little festivals
in the summer
you have little
things where you let you go let's be
festive we all hate each other and we
all don't have any money
but what we have right now is we can
they will legally allow us to block off
each side of our street so that we can
get drunk in the middle of our street
and we can set up a few tables with hot
dogs
and that will be our summer
festival
it's like have you ever been to one of
these i've been more than i want to
admit yeah and sometimes there's a
parade too right sometimes there's a
parade the local marching band yeah
bring out the local marching band and
the lions club there's like an old
people walking there's they're walking
or it's independence day it's the
ancient order of hibernians it's the
[ __ ]
knights of malta whatever it is it's you
got every old group there's five
veterans they all [ __ ]
lit babies on fire in vietnam
and they're marching and everyone's like
thank you for your service they all did
the my life massacre and they're all
walking around and then we just cordon
off our street so that everybody can eat
grizzle burgers and drink booze and
listen to the sound of gunshots it's the
summer
in america it's a beautiful place and a
beautiful time you should enjoy it if
you're rich you get to do many other
things but if you are not this is what
your summer looks like in america
it looks like a street festival
where
your white child is dressed like a gang
banger
and you are telling the neighbor that
he's doing quote much better
that is summer
in america
if you don't have a lot of money
you will not be
in the south of france
you will not be on nantucket
maybe you are
at a nice little street festival in a
suburb of tampa
talking about your daughter who has
three children now
she's 24 years old and she's just had
her third child and you're telling the
neighbors how cute they are but they can
hear there's a hint of worry in your
voice
summer in the usa that's what it is and
there's nothing wrong with it there's
nothing wrong and your big fat daughter
waddles out with her three mistakes and
she's got a tattoo on her big rib eye
sigh steak size foot and she comes out
and she cracks open a beer and she goes
is there a burger
she has a long island accent because you
guys move there
and you go oh i thought moving her down
to tampa would calm her the [ __ ] down
but she spit out three kids you know
she's a cashier at a gas station there's
nothing wrong with that
absolutely nothing wrong but she's
stealing
and there's something wrong with that
because you know that that job's not
gonna last forever
but she's getting along with her brother
better now probably because you're both
cooking meth together in the backyard
have some potato salad we got it at the
store it's summer in america you're to
enjoy it there's no school
so that means the kids have to shoot
each other somewhere else and it won't
make the news
isn't that nice
it's summer in america
let your children run around they're
being chased through the town by
pedophiles
summer in america put them in a
recreation program where some weird 45
year old single freak wants to watch
them run around and you're very nervous
summer in america enjoy it it's fun
there's nothing wrong with it
send the kids to camp
they can come back trans
nothing wrong with that depends on which
camp they go to
send them to uh you know in the woods
camp they come back talking about the
shapes of skulls and jews
send them to a theater arts camp they
come back with blue hair telling you you
don't even own the house you live in
you're colonizing pig
you gotta but get them away from you you
deserve it it's summer and summer
my greatest summer memories all involved
drugs and trying to do cocaine before it
melted because cocaine will melt
and if you can get it in your nose
before it melts it can be a lovely
evening nothing better than uh doing a
cocaine
on a nice
summer night
truly i'm not kidding it's really good
if you are young and you are listening
to this show
there's nothing better for you to do
with your life than snort cocaine and
smoke cigarettes in the summer
and why
and then stop
when you have to
just stop it just say okay now no more
now no more but do it and enjoy it but
then go no no no now i'm done
summer in america is one of those things
where
it's it's far too short but it's very
intense and it's it's i love it it's hot
and disgusting and i used to hang out
with people we used to sit in the
projects
and we'd do coke
me and my friend and we'd sit there and
he was a little chubby kid me me and him
just two little fat chubby kids in the
projects sitting there on a dirty bed
with no [ __ ] sheet and then uh uh
some
woman who would be there and she'd be
like cutting lines and we'd be sitting
there and we'd all just sniff uh the
lines and then we'd smoke cigarettes and
be like 1am in the summer and we'd all
ash them in an ashtray that had like
already like 80 or 90 cigarettes in it
and we'd just sit there and we'd look
and then one of us would see like a big
roach and point and go oh look at that
and the big roach would walk around and
then like in another room a baby you'd
be like
and she'd be she'd go comfort the baby
or maybe sometimes not and it was just
that's
awesome
you know just the heat and the summer
and so that's really part of what i
think makes summer special is it's it's
the time where you could find out what
kind of person you want to be
because when you're in school and stuff
like that there's so many pressures
summer is about you
it's about getting out there and
figuring out
who you want to be like what kind of
person do you want to be
you know like you know that's really
what summer is you can go out you can
experiment with things and figure out
like who you are
you know it's where you take a little
trip you go stay with your aunt
in a different part of the world or
different part of the country and you go
like haze is this for me
do i want to be this you know is this
the type of person i want to be you know
like that's what the summer is my
parents never sent me to camp
they never sent me to camp so i did
drugs with the local children
because i didn't go to a camp my father
said camp is for jewish people which
meant camp is for people that had money
my father didn't have any money
so i would just kind of spend my summers
with my friends
doing drugs in long island and they were
great summers and that's when i realized
i really wanted to be a drug addict i
realized that when i was 13 or 14 i said
i want to be addicted to drugs and i was
for 10 years until i was 25 i said i
want to be a drug addicted moral coward
that has absolutely no sense of self i
want to spend the majority of my life
shoving things in
my nose to try to feel good
and i want to make a mess of myself
financially and physically and really
walk myself to the brink of death over
and over and over and over again until
finally i came back from that ledge but
again that was my journey it's not
everybody's journey some people figure
out they go i like rowing so it's not
everyone's journey but i'll tell you i'm
glad i had it so if you're young and
you're listening to this show
maybe for the first 10 years of your
life be a drug addict who steals from
your family
why and then just stop and go okay i'm
done with that right now i'm done
just go just go
out mulligan
it's the summer in america i i have
great summer memory what are you give us
one summer memory because i've just gone
through so many but just give us is
there one thing that sticks out in your
head as a summer memory that that you
go like you know i i remember this
summer memory i remember uh sitting in
the woods in my backyard with an ice
cream cone and sharing it with my dog so
my dog would lick it and then i would
lick it and it was just a hot summer day
that's disgusting
every day he gets closer and closer to
being permanently removed
every day he's closer and closer to
being permanently removed from this show
i cannot imagine
um
it's like it's crazy just
the behavior every day with you is this
a working fireplace bobby
the great bobby hutcher's with us uh no
it used to be a working fireplace but
not anymore fair enough
[Music]
i i love underwear i've said that many
times and i love me undies have you ever
had used me on this oh yeah i love me
are people still trying to make plans
with you this summer as if you aren't
booked and busy already you're just
gonna have to tell them to try again in
the fall you've got pool days pride
parades bachelor parties and beach
vacations waiting for you it's a lot but
thankfully meundies wants to help make
this summer the most comfortable one
you'll never forget why because when
you're living your best life the last
thing you want to worry about is butt
sweat
when you're comfy and feeling good
you're more present to enjoy all your
summer plans it's like science or
something me undies has the lightest and
most breathable fabric to keep you cool
and comfortable wherever you go from
undies bralettes socks loungewear
swimwear you can find something for all
of your plans me undies releases new
prints all the time like their limited
edition pride collection you can match
with your partner friends or even your
dog
find your ultimate summer comfort and
sizes from extra small to 4xl meundies
has a great offer for my listeners for
any first-time purchasers you get 15 off
for a limited time if you sign up for
their free to join me on these
membership you get 25 off your first
membership item to get 25 off your first
order 25 off your first membership item
and 100 satisfaction guarantee go to
meundies.com tim
that's meundies.com
t-i-m
and we we wear me undies you wear them i
wear them i wear them yeah i wear my
undies you wear them everyone wears them
yeah
mud water is a coffee alternative with
four after genetic mushrooms with
ayurvedic herbs with one-seventh the
caffeine is a cup of coffee i love this
stuff you get your energy without the
anxiety jitters and crash of coffee each
ingredient was added for a purpose cacao
and chai for mood and micro dose of
caffeine lines made for alertness
cordyceps to help support physical
performance chaga and rishi to support
your immune system turmeric for soreness
turmeric turmeric turmeric and cinnamon
for antioxidants
i
love it what's your favorite flavor
my favorite flavor would probably be
that's right
mud is a whole30 approved 100 usda
organic non-gmo gluten-free vegan and
kosher certified mud water has launched
their new evening ritual the rest blend
a non-caffeinated tea that promotes
relaxation and rest because the best
morning ritual starts the night before
go to mudwater.com to support the show
and use code tim for five percent off
that's mud
wtr.com
to support the show and use the code tim
for five dollars off what should they do
if they want to get involved with this
go to mudwater.com and support the show
and use the code tim for five dollars
off and uh i like the nighttime drink
blend that one calms me down that one's
been my favorite so far yeah let's talk
about this pride what's going on here
with the pride if you heard this
they're saying about foods that you can
eat and it's getting strange um because
on they're they're all trying to be
allies these companies you know like the
good companies of the world
and you know i'm not one of these
anti-corporate lunatics you know i i i
uh i think it's uh every now and then
the corporations can do good things
right the fudgy the whale and and so so
on and so forth there's things i like
now
but they're these corporations it's a
it's gay overload as a gay person i'm
telling you it's too much it's too much
now
uh whereas every corporation is
offensively gay
and it's to a point where like people
are like i don't know it's
it it it fetishizes gay people and it
does not treat them like human beings
that's my issue with it you don't have
uh nobody's uh treated with any dignity
it's just this crass marketing scheme
tell us a little bit about what the what
they've done here at ubereats oh yeah
well the postmates commercial oh yeah
i'm sorry well there's a lot of them
that are they're all owned by the same
company right that's true and they're
also these people are just stepping on
rakes everywhere they go like burger
king had the two equal buns right so
burger king's doing top and bottom yeah
yeah it's so crazy i mean it is
offensive but uh
because there's why it's offensive
they're saying that some people are tops
and some people are bottoms and
you could walk around like hey i'm
having a burger with two tops or it
should be here's why it's offensive what
if you're in a blood play
some people can't even come anally they
need blood play
which means that you cut someone and
lick their blood or squirt their blood
into your mouth or your eyes
if you're a bug chaser and you can only
come
thinking you could get aids you want
aids where is the meal for you
there's some people that can only get
off being pissed on some people like
[ __ ]
where is their men do they have a menu
for people that like [ __ ] play oh yes
hey bobby can you i just emailed it to
you there's a bottom pride postmates
commercial if you could play it yeah
bottom pride which is i guess if you eat
a lot of yogurt here's what i found you
can get [ __ ] in the ass after eating
really anything
it doesn't really matter it's just an
[ __ ] it doesn't really matter stop
trying to make it so nice for the other
person
um
here is this about what you should eat
before you get [ __ ] in the ass
what are you eating this pride
anything if you're a top it seems like
you can eat whatever you
want but if you're a bottom you're
expected to starve
not this pride introducing the bottom
friendly menu from postmates
what's on that we teamed up with dr evan
goldstein from bespoke surgical to bring
you a menu of bottom friendly foods
backed by science
insoluble fiber won't help you feel cute
so avoid things like whole grains sweet
bran cauliflower potatoes legumes
hold up are you just fully diving into
those beans
the problem with these foods is they
don't dissolve in water which could
cause a traffic jam in your digestive
system here's the deal
you can get [ __ ] in the ass after
eating potatoes
right
i mean
i don't understand a problem
i mean you
i usually i mean there's only real
problems with that when like you eat
something crazy
you know but i think for them you don't
have to just eat yogurt the whole day
you can just go on about your life and
then just get [ __ ] in the ass and the
worst thing that happens is i guess you
would just [ __ ] on someone's dick
which it's not a nice thing to do
but if you do it i mean what i mean
what's the problem but my concern about
all this here is it reduces gay people
to number one it's all sex
it's there's nothing about it you know
you wouldn't do this to any other group
of people
you know right would you do this on
black history month and have like an
anti-diabetes diet and go hey let's hold
it down with the soul food this month
don't you want to be around next black
history month
how about some salads
why would you would you do that no you
couldn't do it wouldn't be right
wouldn't be right
so i just think this is strange and i
also think like if you're gonna have
what about trans
non-binary and
why not every gender should have some
type of menu
you know
what about the menu for a [ __ ] you
know
[ __ ]
sapiosexual
demi-plebes
that like to be dominated
what about that
what about the bdsm menu
what kind of foods should i eat before
i'm choked on the stairs
is there an is there a type of panini i
should eat before i cut off your oxygen
and watch you squirm like a fish
because that's the only way i can come i
can't come unless you're fighting for
air
like someone that's collapsed in the
rubble of the twin towers
what is the appropriate hot dog to eat
before that anything
but these companies here's what i'm
saying these companies
are bobby order us at pizza is anyone
getting [ __ ] in the ass tonight
do they have a problem with pizza bobby
i'll pay for it just order us a regular
pizza and are you staying too you're
gonna be here do you eat food or you're
some kind of freak okay
well you don't know it's new york people
have vegan problems and [ __ ] um
bobby get us um is there a place here
you order from
yeah there's a place down the block
that's really good yeah get us um
because there's four of us get us uh
get us a pizza and also get us like a uh
maybe a calzone absolutely yeah get us a
plain pizza
uh unless you guys want anything on it
but a plain cheese pizza
and uh and a calzone
and some wings if they have wings gotcha
thank you bobby
and we'll edit that out we'll add it to
pizza ordering out oh well no i had that
funny bit about where i said is anyone
getting [ __ ] in the air
keep it all in it's filler
um
but i'll tell you this folks uh
i just i just think it's a little crass
what's going on right now it's a little
crass like they have to show heart
stopper on netflix which is about these
two gay guys which is great but you know
one of the kids again he does the same
thing right this young adult actor does
the same thing he's like hey he goes i
know you people want queer
representation to be authentic which by
the way i don't give a [ __ ] about i
don't care who you [ __ ] i think you're
an actor
actors you can play anything it doesn't
bother me straight people playing gay
people none of it bothers me right um
but he goes i know people want queer
representation to be authentic but you
shouldn't have to tell a stranger your
sexuality i refuse to and it's like well
the kid's clearly just straight it's
just a straight actor right playing a
gay role which is fine but i mean like
it's what it is
clearly what it is he's like i won't
tell my sexuality to a stranger by the
way when i was growing up the entire
crux
of being a gay person was
to tell your sexuality to a stranger the
point is more and more gay people made
people go oh
there's tons of gay this is like a small
subset of people
they're small relative to the population
but like oh we know gay people they're
not crazy freak monsters and all that
[ __ ] so the idea that like it's funny
now that it's completely reversed where
someone can just go i'm not telling my
sexuality to a stranger
i would never how dare you ask me to
reveal my sexuality it's like
it's such an about and he's applauded
for that
people on twitter are like that's right
yeah yeah
yeah yeah
i'm like well what's so wrong about
admitting
your sexuality i mean that's the whole
thing right
or it used to be it used to be living an
honest life was commendable and
respectable that was what used to be
um
value but now it has just become you
know everything again has become like a
marketing scheme
so the response is always like well i
know they want queer representation to
be authentic but i you shouldn't have to
tell a stranger your sexuality it's like
just say you're straight and then
they'll throw fit
let them throw fit fight that battle
go i'm straight
i'm sorry i want to [ __ ] women but i'm
comfortable enough with myself to make
out with this dude on netflix for money
which anyone should do because the
economy is crumbling he is he so
um just say that fight that battle go i
am straight but i'll tell you this
if you know i was given the chance to
become famous by hooking up with a guy
and doing a gay show i have no problem
playing gay actors used to not like to
play gay but now it's fine so that's
progressive but don't lie
and be like i'll never review i'm not
gonna reveal my sexuality and then the
other time he said like something about
it he's like well i guess the press
knows more about my sexuality than i do
it's like what do you talk you're an
adult you know who you want to [ __ ]
already see you stop this nonsense
maybe it's a little bit of a journey but
you have an inkling you have an inkling
about who you want to [ __ ]
you know whatever i have no beef with
the person i'm not even going to say
their name is just again it's not the
only person doing it there's like 10
actors now that are playing gay that are
clearly not gay and clearly are in this
weird trap of not being able to come out
as straight which is hilarious
because the lunatics on twitter will be
like they should have hired a gay actor
well this guy is a very attractive guy
and maybe they didn't want maybe they
didn't have his look in gay
he walked in and he was the better actor
he should get the job
you know
so to me but it's just funny to me and
it is
kind of hilarious to like these some of
these guys are trapped they have these
queer gay whatever fan bases
um
and they're like terrified they're
terrified of like coming out astray and
going like hey i'm an ally i love gay
culture i'm in a show making out with
dude i clearly have no problem but i
like [ __ ] sorry
i like [ __ ] and then that would be okay
but but if that happened they'd be like
you see
you see
so this poor dude you can see it in his
face too he's like trapped he's gonna
have to [ __ ] a guy
even though he doesn't want to like
that's maybe i think what he's gonna
have to do
he's gonna have to like let a guy blow
him and just close his eyes and be like
pansexual or whatever like because i get
it the checks are the checks
you know we love steve will do it from
nelk he is a good man and he's a good
man because he's from florida and you
would think someone like steve would be
dead dead on the street because he got
famous by drinking bottles of jack
daniel and like they'd put him in a fish
tank of booze and he'd drink it all and
he never died
and that must mean that he's a saint or
the second coming of jesus christ if
jesus came back wouldn't he be in an
online prank duo that recently launched
a hard sell sir that's what i think
there's something magical about steve
will do it mystical if you will
you know he's a very interesting guy
he's he's uh you know able to do perform
these great feats
right like uh drink a bottle of jack
daniels at once or something that jesus
would do if he was back right i mean
it's not just a party trick i mean the
things that this guy has done i mean
doctors will tell you he should be out
stone cold on the floor dead but he's
not
he's launching products and helping
people giving poor people crypto and
houses he's out there on the streets
helping kids with cancer learn how to
gamble
steve will do it we'll do it that's the
greatest thing about him he's part of
the group nelk but he's also his own
thing he's the breakout star there's
been a few other people in that group
where are they now they live on the
street these people but steve will do it
has really made the most of his whole
thing there
um
you know
um and and good and and we're just happy
that he
uh it helps us here at the show
and i think he gave me bitcoin to do
this and i i mean it dropped like 20
grand as soon as he gave it to me he
knew it was coming but you know that we
but i appreciate that because he timed
the market he gets in
he gets it
steve will do it what's his youtube
channel so go to steve we'll do it on
youtube he has two channels steve will
do it and then steve will do it too
where he gambles he plays online casinos
and slots and roulette it's a great
country if you let it be
steve will do it go check this guy out
we love him and you'll love him too and
if you've got cancer he just may give
you some ethereum
we have a live podcast august 8th in
west hampton beach in long island it
will feature myself benjamin and ray
comp
out in the hamptons you should come see
it it's going to be a lot of fun you
know who's going to be a guest on it
jerry seinfeld oh wow
jerry
seinfeld now if here's i'm going to tell
you right now
if he cancels last minute and doesn't
show up that's not my fault that's true
but as of right now
jerry seinfeld
and alec baldwin
are gonna be guests on the show and if
they cancel they cancel it's what it is
and that'll be sunday august 7th that's
right spend that money
get that ticket at the west hampton
beach performing at the west hampton
beach performing arts center west
hampton shittiest hampton other than
hampton bays right that's true so come
on out we're doing a live
two-hour podcast all about
long iron
and uh
it's gonna be interesting
and uh it'll be enjoyable
uh ben do you have anything to plug
uh no uh
just my twitter well you're also do you
want to tell them you you also you tried
to start your own merch line
and i called the police
ben tried to start his own merch line
right
you want to show them the photo yeah
i'll show them the photo show them the
photo of what you tried to do
now you tried to do this and i caught
you immediately and i contacted the
federal bureau of investigation and
they've opened an investigation into you
and i hope the result of that
investigation is that you serve time
what can you what is that
no one can even oh there it is there it
is
now of course this is a joke this is
something that your wife's mom made for
you my mother-in-law she right that's
that's what i said
well yeah it's just mother-in-law's
easier okay
and she made that for you yes very sweet
she put my logo
on something did she ask me for
permission well it's technically a
little different you can tell she like
stenciled it
we'll see how different it is
because she took my name right your name
is on it yeah she took my name and she
put it on something without my
permission that's correct yeah yeah is
that correct that's correct okay well
we'll deal with that
we'll be dealing with it legally okay
and let's just say
we're gonna be dealing with it legally
okay this is the type of thing that we
have to be nipped in the butt
immediately are you suing me or you
suing uh my wife's family broad brush
everybody's gonna get something
everybody's gonna get it because
otherwise if i'm taking advantage of
like this consistently and i don't step
in and say no
it will never end
and i worry i worry about what this can
be
disgusting good luck